they had made allegations that these
people were part of a Coptic Crusade
group and that they were responsible for
the forced conversion of Muslim women
into Christianity which of course
neither of those is true we've seen such
restraint from the Christians of Egypt
over over centuries and over the last
decades in particular and what we find
this is rhetoric that then builds up and
creates this narrative that is then
believed but nonetheless the action of
the current Egyptian government in
taking these military strikes so it
makes it clear that they don't subscribe
to this idea of there being some kind of
crusade underway
well I it doesn't make sense that there
would be within our history in Egypt
there has never been any kind of
aggression shown by the Christians there
in actual fact my concern more than
what's happening recently is that
there's a dehumanization of people that
that these poor men were paraded on the
beach almost as as war trophies and then
they would be humanized and
depersonalized and shown off in this way
and I think when we do that it's much
easier to inflict this kind of brutality
but my call as a religious leader to
other people who would consider
themselves as a religious is let's look
at the humanity of people and try to
find that kind of solution because if
some of these people are faithful in
what they're doing and they really
believe that this is the way of
practicing their faith then surely they
must have an idea of sanctity of life
and that sanctity of life exists across
all people I mean the problem is that as
far as we can understand from the faith
which the Islamic state profess they
don't see it that way that basically
either you join them or you are killed
or enslaved absolutely there is a very
narrowing perspective of who is accepted
by is at the moment and I think it
really is time for for Islamic teachers
to create a counter narrative to that
and to demonstrate to people
may be taken in by this we saw the
glorification of these killings and
these videos which are very polished and
very choreographed that there is no
glory in death and that if the
interpretation is proposed in this way
then sure there must be another one you
talked about the difficulty of Egyptian
cops over the last decade or so is it
not now the case though that the
regime's for example we saw in Jordan
last week and now in Egypt are more open
to a number of faiths within their
company within their countries then
certainly the previous government in
Egypt was well there has been a marked
improvement in Egypt and and what we
need to draw a distinction between the
fact that these acts were actually
carried out in Libya this time not in
Egypt which is a very new fact that
America Network absolute they've gone
there to work from underprivileged
families and and just to send money back
to their to their families and they now
have lost valued numbers how widespread
is the Coptic faith in the Middle East
well the Coptic Church was established
in Egypt 2,000 years ago it is the
largest bulk of Christian presence in
the Middle East between twelve and
fifteen million and ninety percent of
Coptic Christians still live in Egypt so
when we then consider ourselves a
Diaspora community were community and
expansion but Christians have a heritage
there and have a placed there and
consider themselves as indigenous people
there